trump is expected to land at mccarran
airport later this evening and will hold
a campaign rally in carson city tomorrow
orco mana has a preview of the
president's visit and how his campaign
is hoping to win the silver state
president donald trump and his team are
making it clear nevada is a big priority
for them in this election
the president is set to hold a make
america great again rally
in carson city on sunday and with
election day just over two weeks away
and early voting
already underway in nevada the trump
team is pulling out all the stops
[Applause]
president trump was last in nevada in
september when he held large rallies in
both minden and henderson the rally in
henderson caused some controversy for
being indoors with few masks and little
social distancing we spoke to the trump
2020 communications director who says
the president's rally in carson city
this sunday will be outdoors he also
says precautions are put in place at all
trump rallies
we temperature check everyone before
they go inside and we give everyone
who goes inside a mask and we instruct
them to wear it
at the end of the day president trump
knows that people are adults people have
first amendment protections
president trump is expected to continue
touting his achievements in the white
house focusing as he usually does on the
economy
the trump team saying the president will
restore the economy to pre-pandemic
levels
the president is making clear and the
people of nevada know this
president trump built the world's best
economy one time and he's already doing
it again
the nevada state democratic party
released a statement in response to
trump's visit saying in part quote
trump's desperate attempts to erase his
failed record won't fool nevadans
during this pandemic and throughout his
presidency trump has chosen to
prioritize his wealthy well-connected
friends over hard-working nevadans
president trump narrowly lost nevada to
hillary clinton in 2016.
the latest cbs news battleground poll
has biden six points
ahead of trump in the newsroom orca mana
8 news now